I had just turned 13 when the first
Harry Potter movie came out
according to Warner Brothers nearly 60%
of the people who saw that movie were 17
or younger that for a whole generation
of us the Harry Potter series spanned
our adolescence and and printed onto our
lives a love of reading but less has
been said about the film's I think their
commitment to good cinematic work was
potentially just as important for young
people's filmic education as JK
Rowling's accomplishments were for our
literary operating for me that all
starts with Alfonzo Quran and the third
film in the series the Prisoner of
Azkaban coming at a crucial time in both
the books and the film's Azkaban marks
Potter's transition from perilous
adventure stories for children mostly
restricted Sakshi to increasingly dark
increasingly nuanced treatments of
character and plot picking Quarren to
handle this passage seems perfect in
retrospect as it set the tone for the
grimmer and grimy ER final installments
of the series but Warner Brothers has to
be credited for taking a chance on a
director whose previous film was an
explicit Mexican roadtrip drama about
sexual discovery a lot of the style of
that film and Clarins previous work is
readily apparent in Azkaban most notably
his fondness for a moving often
hand-held camera just take a quick sped
up look at this early scene from the
Great Hall not a single shot is
stationary this gives the scene and the
film a feeling of forward momentum and
establishes a curious camera but it also
lends to the film a sense of unease an
inability to find stable footing now for
a film that is to be haunted by a feared
killer throughout such a style is
fitting and this isn't the only
signature technique Horan brings to
Potter his famous use of the long take
is here as well this shot right here is
a minute and 49 seconds long and as the
critic Kristin Thompson has noted it
marks a crucial tonal shift in the film
and the first two scenes
in which Harry blows up his horrible
aunt and one which he takes a ride on
the ridiculous night bus are both pretty
light-hearted you could almost say that
these two scenes are a nod to the two
comparatively lighter films that came
before this in this scene and this shot
Harry learns of the true danger he faces
and what's important to notice here is
that with deeper more significant peril
comes deeper more significant isolation
mr. Weasley pulls Harry into another
part of the leaky cauldron separating
him from his friends while keeping the
specter of Sirius Black in the
foreground when the conversation turns
explicitly to black his image is placed
between them with family and friends
framed in the background then mr.
Weasley pulls Harry into an alcove so
that they are alone asking Harry not to
go looking for black and finally for the
key dramatic question and period on the
scene while Ron frames Harry completely
by himself now this is great
filming isolation will go on to be a key
theme in Azkaban and the rest of the
series despite its constant message of
friendship and its focus on the bond
between Harry Ron and Hermione the
series returns repeatedly to Harry's
feelings of being alone the chosen one
his gradual realization of a burden that
he must carry without help the Prisoner
of Azkaban reflects deepens and
foreshadows these feelings by separating
Harry out from his surroundings or else
placing him apart from those around him
Horan never misses a chance to return to
this theme whether it means separating
Harry from his friends in a shot about
something else telling Emma Watson to
Neil out of a shot or ending the movie
by having Harry literally fly away from
a crowd internal consistency this is one
of Iran's major strengths that's what
makes the Prisoner of Azkaban a cut
above the rest of the films in the
series some of which are quite good
motifs shoot back and forth across the
runtime like magic spells and comment on
each other
tightening a web
Lisa's meaning throughout little things
like following empty footsteps in the
snow before introducing a key object
that visualizes people moving through
Hogwarts castle with footsteps some
immediate foreshadowing there but what
about some longer foreshadowing maybe a
little bird that flies around the
grounds in the beginning of the film two
places it will only later occur to us
that map the sights of significant
scenes in the movie or what about
something more meaningful like Lauren's
recurring motif of moving the camera
through glass a motif that pays off
twice in this scene where the students
fight off a boggart a creature that
visualizes your worst fear twice in this
scene in two beautiful shots the camera
moves through the mirrors of this
wardrobe suggesting that while it's
important to look through windows and
see the world
you can also look through mirrors which
is to say into yourself not to mention
that these shots just make you think
wait how did he do that a great question
for any young film goer to ask and
that's the point here isn't it we hear
so much about a film industry that
continues to pump out crap films that's
ruled by lowest-common-denominator fare
oh there are a number of reasons for
that but one of them is that a lot of
the movie-going public suffers from
cinematic illiteracy we don't know what
makes a good film so the industry serves
up superficial projects that play on
cheap emotions and make us into passive
viewers but learning film is always an
active enterprise all great movies are
teaching movies because they encourage
us to participate with them and with the
whole of cinema this is why the prisoner
of azkaban is so important like anything
it's easy to develop a taste for
something when we learn it young Harry
Potter is a mega franchise won millions
of kids bought tickets for and millions
more will watch and re-watch at home
having a great film like
this in that roster well the results
could be exponential small light that in
the end shines much brighter than anyone
would expect everybody thanks for
watching obviously I'm a huge Harry
Potter fan I grew up with those books
those ages at the beginning were
actually my ages so this was a blast to
make I want to thank you guys actually
because a lot of people actually pledged
a dollar or three dollars after last
week's video and those small pledges
really mean so much because what matters
to me is that if you have the ability to
pledge trying to do so over a long term
period because the patreon is really my
salary so knowing what I'm gonna get
gives me the ability to plan new
projects bigger projects in the future
it just makes everything a lot more
stable so I'd rather you do a dollar you
know over a year then you know five
dollars or ten dollars over a couple
weeks obviously if you can do five
dollars over a year you're amazing and I
can't even believe it but thank you guys
for everything you've donated to this
channel it's been amazing it's helped me
grow this thing and it's growing really
fast now and it's really exciting people
are watching and paying attention which
is all I ever wanted to start so thank
you again I will see you guys next
Wednesday